there was an inter college dance
competition for which a few boys and a
few girls were to be selected so this is
what we have with us out of the ten boys
and the eight girls three boys and three
girls were to be selected in how many
ways can this be done let's try and
understand the question well there are a
total of ten boys and eight girls and
out of these we need to select three
boys and three girls the best way to
understand this is by considering the
boys and the girls separately so the two
cases are selecting three boys out of
ten and selecting three girls out of
eight in fact separating the two cases
was necessary we cannot select boys from
the group of girls or vice-versa
that doesn't make sense let's first look
at selecting three boys out of ten
before we begin solving any permutation
and combination problem you should know
if the order matters or not does the
order matter here to know if the order
matters simply read the statement well
selecting three out of ten is there any
other condition there isn't selecting b1
b2 b3 is the same as selecting b2 b1 b3
or b3 b2 b1 we are just selecting 3 and
similarly the order does not matter for
selecting 3 girls out of 8 how do we
solve this problem we haven't seen the P
and C formula yet how do we solve this
problem based on logic okay how about we
solve this case first then this one and
then we will see what to do so selection
of three boys out of ten we know that
there are ten boys we can select any
three boys to show that we can say as
three times what about the remaining
seven each of them is not selected out
of ten three are selected and seven are
not selected and this becomes a classic
case of the anagram problems we have
seen there are 10 people
so 10 factorial will include all
possibilities now this 10 factorial
assumes that each of these 10 cases is
different but that's not true
these 3 are not distinct and these 7
also are not distinct now how does this
10 factorial count the cases of 3 boys
being selected it assumes that B 1 B 2 B
3 is different from B 2 B 1 B 3 or B 3 B
2 B 1 and so on there are three
factorial or six such ways which 10
factorial assumes to be different but
all these are the same the order does
not matter so to eliminate the repeated
cases we divide this by 3 factorial and
as there are 7 boys that are not
selected we divided again by 7 factorial
that's the answer for this part these
many ways in which we can select 3 boys
out of 10 if you're not sure about how
we got this please go through our video
based on anagrams and you will surely
get a better idea now we can move on to
the second part of selecting 3 girls out
of 8 there are 8 girls in all using this
concept that we just learnt can you find
the number of ways in which we can
select 3 girls out of the 8 I am sure
all of you got it right as 3 girls are
selected we write as 3 times and the
remaining 5 are not selected so we write
NS 5 times out of these 8 these 3 are
similar and these 5 are also similar as
there are 8 girls we write 8 factorial
here and this includes all possibilities
assuming each of the 8 cases are
different but we know that they are not
for this we divide 8 factorial by 3
factorial and for this we divided by 5
factorial these many ways in which we
can select 3 girls out of 8 some of you
might wonder why I don't solve these
factorials that's
cause in the exams in all probability
your answer choices will also be in
factorial form especially when the
answer is huge and I'm sure you can
solve these pretty easily to get the
numerical value that's not the important
part the important part is understanding
how we cut this but wait we have the
answers for each of these two cases
boys and girls what's the answer to the
question the question asks us to find
the number of ways in which we can
select three boys and three girls out of
ten boys and eight girls so do we add
these two or multiply them the question
gives us the answer three boys and three
girls and always implies multiplication
so we multiply these two and this
becomes our final answer if you solve
this you should get the answer as six
thousand seven hundred and twenty six
thousand seven hundred and twenty ways
in which we can select three boys and
three girls from ten boys and eight
girls
you